Oui. Ok.
C'est échelonnable
sur combien de temps ?
Vous êtes sûr ? Deux mois de retard ?
Oui, parce que…
Ok. Ça marche.
Par chèque, sans faute.
Merci, madame, merci beaucoup.
Au revoir.
Maman ?
- Oui ?
- Je vais y aller, là.
Ok. Bon courage, Oussou.
- Ça va aller ?
- Oui.
Ton petit frère, il n'a pas école,
il va s'occuper de moi.
Ok. Ça marche.
Bon, allez.
Hey, Abidou !
Amidou !
Tu fais quoi ?
Pourquoi tu as dit à la daronne
que tu n'as pas école ?
- Je n'ai pas école.
- Tu es sûr ?
Oui, la prof n'est pas là.
Attends, tu vas voir, toi.
Il se fout de ma gueule.
Il n'a jamais école, celui-là.
Putain.
Frérot, je t'ai dit que j'arrive.
Tu es un excité, toi.
Je suis là.
Tout stressé.
Respire, frère.
Oh !
Respire !
Vas-y, tu as grillé
tous les feux rouges, et tout.
Tu es un malade, toi,
mon frère, tu m'as fait peur.
Heureusement que j'ai speedé,
dis-moi merci.
Les gars, dites-moi merci.
Frère, regarde, il est quelle heure ?
On arrive en avance.
Tu es détendu.
Tu sais que ça joue de ouf.
Non, mais il abuse, lui.
Les PDG, ils n'arrivent pas en avance.
Tu vois, ils sont tranquilles,
ils arrivent quand ils veulent.
Excuse-moi frérot, mais les PDG,
ils ont du style et ils ont du flow.
- J'ai du flow, moi.
- Ton costard,
ça fait 78 fois que tu le mets.
Regarde comme il compressé dedans.
Je t'ai dit de ne pas le mettre,
celui-là.
Arrête de me stresser, s'il te plaît.
C'est bon, je l'ai déjà mis,
je l'ai déjà mis de toute façon,
on s'en fout, je l'ai déjà mis.
Dis-moi ce qu'il a fait.
Il a mis les chaussettes blanches.
Téma ses chaussettes blanches !
- C'est grave, ça !
- Comment tu peux faire ça, gros.
Frère, ça fait un rappel de couleur
avec la chemise.
- Je n'y connais rien, moi...
- Quel rappel de couleur ?
c'est une faute de goût, arrête ça.
- On dirait un villageois, là.
- Personne ne regarde les chaussettes !
Tout le monde regarde les chaussettes.
Tu me fais mal à la tête,
personne ne regarde les chaussettes.
Messieurs,
qu'est-ce que je peux vous servir ?
De l'eau, de l'eau pour moi.
- Pareil.
- Plate ou gazeuse ?
- Carafe.
Pour vous ?
Je vais vous prendre
un diabolo fraise, alors.
Oui, ça vous fera 5,50 euros.
- Cinq euros…
- Quoi ?
Ya !
Je peux vous encaisser maintenant.
Oui.
Frère, 5,50,
c'est un grec plus boisson, frère.
Là, il n'a que la boisson.
Alors...
- Il y a… je ne sais pas.
- Jamais il n'a le compte.
Super.
Comptez bien, on ne sait jamais.
Comptez bien
toute la monnaie de la tirelire.
Merci.
Un diabolo fraise.
Frères, vous ne prenez rien.
Je vais vous prendre un kir royal,
bientôt, s'il vous plaît,
un petit kir royal.
Un kir pêche.
- Bonjour.
J'ai rendez-vous avec monsieur Bernier.
Oui. Bien sûr, vous êtes ?
Ousmane Bah.
C'est la porte au fond du couloir.
- Merci.
- Avec plaisir.
Putain.
Ouais.
Ah ! Je peux repasser,
je suis un peu en avance.
- Ousmane.
- Oui.
Ousmane, vas-y, rentre.
Mets-toi à l'aise.
Vas-y, je t'en prie, rentre.
C'est juste que Khalil
est en avance, mais...
alors, il n'y a pas de souci. Vas-y.
Asseyez-vous, je suis à vous
dans deux minutes. D'accord ?
Oui.
Pas de problème.
Oui, Sandra, oui.
Ah ! Ils sont là. Ok.
Écoute, tu les fais
patienter dix minutes ?
Je termine le brief
avec les nouveaux collaborateurs, là.
Ok, ça marche, à tout à l'heure.
J'arrive.
Et voilà, hop !
Ok.
Ça va ?
- Ça va, et toi ?
- Oui. Pas trop relou pour venir ?
- Non, ça a été.
- Il y avait du monde ?
Un petit peu.
Écoutez, déjà bienvenue à Big City.
- Merci.
On est plutôt bien ici,
c'est cool, hein ?
- C'est super.
- C'est cool, hein !
Je suis ravi que vous soyez là,
tous les deux, vraiment.
Merci beaucoup.
J'ai reçu vos dossiers.
Pardon, tu veux un café ?
Ah ! Non, je vous remercie, ça va.
Je t'arrête tout de suite,
ici on ne se vouvoie pas, d'accord ?
Ça me fout des angoisses, c'est chiant.
On se dit tu, Ok ?
Tu. Tu.
Très bien.
- Tu en veux un autre ?
- Ça va aller, je te remercie, Éric.
C'est gentil.
Écoutez, je veux que vous sachiez
que vous avez été recrutés
parce qu'ici,
la boîte se base uniquement
sur le mérite
et le potentiel des candidats.
Et moi, je vous ai repérés,
car je suis convaincu
que vous avez le profil idéal
pour mener à bien la mission
que je vais vous présenter.
- Ok ?
- Ok.
Pour commencer, est-ce que
vous vous êtes un peu renseignés,
déjà, sur ce qu'on fait ici ?
- Oui.
- Ouais ?
- Vas-y, je t'écoute.
- Je sais que Big City,
c'est l'entreprise qui a pour but
de faciliter la transition
vers le Grand Paris.
- Enfin, si je ne me trompe pas.
- Ouais. Super,
Tu as lu la brochure, c'est cool.
C'est ça.
C'est exactement ça.
C'est ça, on veut avancer
vers le Grand Paris,
et pour ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On va réaménager la périphérie.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va créer
de nouveaux espaces, propres,
modernes pour accueillir
les nouvelles lignes de métro.
- Très bien.
- Vous savez, les prolongements,
la petite couronne, grande couronne.
- Tout à fait.
- Tous ces trucs-là,
Vous voyez le délire.
Cool. D'ailleurs, vous vivez où ?
Vous êtes de banlieue ?
Oui, je n'ai jamais bougé.
Toujours vécu en banlieue ?
- Oui.
- Également,
je viens de déménager
du côté de Montreuil.
- Ligne 9.
- Oui, c'est ça.
- Croix de Chavaux, tout ça.
- Croix de Chavaux.
Tu connais.
Cool.
Du coup,
vous connaissez bien le terrain.
On est quand même d'accord
pour dire que là-bas,
il y a des familles qui vivent juste
dans des conditions insalubres.
Oui.
Enfin, je ne veux pas,
mais sans déconner,
on est au XIXe siècle.
C'est dégueulasse,
ce n'est même pas aux normes.
Je ne sais pas
ce que vous en pensez, vous.
Oui, si on pouvait faire quelque chose
pour la qualité de vie là-bas,
l'améliorer, en tout cas,
parce que les conditions, là-bas,
sont de plus en plus déplorables.
Oui. Grave.
Du coup, l'idée c'est ça.
On va créer des lotissements décents,
et encore quand je dis décents,
je suis en dessous de la normale.
Là, sur le coup
on a des architectes de malade,
on va faire des espaces propres,
"Green", des trucs avec du style.
Ok ?
Mais pour arriver à cette finalité,
il faut que les gens qui vivent là-bas
acceptent de partir
le plus vite possible.
Ok. D'accord.
Il y a autre chose.
Il faut qu'on les fasse partir
dans les trois mois.
C'est la deadline,
parce que sinon
on va laisser passer les contrats.
Si on n'a pas les contrats,
pas de CDI, pas de prime,
pas de voiture de fonction.
Enfin, vous voyez le…
Oui.
Ok. Vous êtes chauds ?
Ben, oui.
Cool. Moi aussi, ça tombe bien.
Allez, on ne perd pas de temps.
On rentre direct dans le vif du sujet.
Ça, c'est les dossiers
avec les fameux locataires
qui ne veulent pas partir.
- Ok.
- Ok ?
Vous avez compris ce qui vous attend ?
- Oui.
- C'est quoi l'objectif ?
Préparer le Grand Paris, j'imagine.
Yes ! C'est ça, c'est mon gars sûr, ça.
On va faire de belles choses, les gars.
Oui ? Oui, merde.
Je vous laisse éplucher ça.
J'ai une réunion parce que…
- du pain sur la planche.
- Ok.
On se retrouve tout à l'heure ?
- Ok. À toute.
- Ça marche.
- Ousmane ?
- Oui ?
Tu t'habilles toujours comme ça, toi ?
Oui.
Ce n'est pas une question piège,
mais juste,
la prochaine fois évite peut-être.
Je ne voudrais pas qu'ils aient peur.
D'accord.
Ok. Pas de costard.
Ça marche.
Ça va ?
Tu habites dans quelle zone
de Montreuil, toi ?